hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
and it's time to see what's making the
headlines with the consultant editor of
the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire and i'm very
pleased to say that they're going to be
with us
right through until midnight for our
extended news review so a very good
evening
so let's take a look at what's on the
front pages and the metro reacts to the
resignation of the government's
education catch-up czar sir kevin
collins
over plans and funding for postcovid
teaching the paper turns its fire on the
education secretary declaring
it's an f for failed gavin
that's also the lead for the daily
telegraph which describes
kevin's resignation statement as
scathing
the daily mail reports that foreign
holidays are under threat
thanks to the spread of a new covert 19
variant
the guardian carries a report into gen
zed
generation zed and how badly young
adults have been impacted by the
policies needed to control the pandemic
and the financial times leads with a
complicated story about commodities
trader
trafigura credit suisse green cell
capital and
steel magnate sanjiv gupta
so andrew pearson kevin mcguire here
with me tonight and uh
good to see you both let's kick off with
the daily telegraph shall we andrew
because it's got a story on its front
page which at least a couple of the
papers are leading with tomorrow and
this is the resignation
of the government's education catch-ups
are the man put in to try and formulate
a plan to make sure that children
got up to speed with the education that
they'd missed he's quit
and it's covered in the papers what do
you make of this
uh it's it's hugely embarrassing
actually for the government because
kevin sir kevin owens sir kevin collins
was only appointed
in february he's a pretty well respected
figure he's a former teacher
he's pretty hot on the the three r's
he's worked in educational charities for
the last decade
uh and um there's net the treasury are
never ever going to agree to demands
uh from for 15 billion pounds
to get schools back where they were a
year ago
but they came so well short what was it
1.4 billion admittedly there was an
extra 1.5 billion last year but so
that's
3 billion so kevin was asking for more
like
15 billion pounds and uh the hapless
gavin williamson
was put out today he's the education
secretary the worst education secretary
i can ever recall to be honest he had to
do the broadcast rounds today
he didn't even know when he was asked
how much
does this money equate to per child
per head he didn't know he had to be
told it was 50 pounds now
kevin collins is saying it's not even
that much in primary schools it's more
like
20 pounds and look you know one of the
biggest losers in the pandemic
have been school kids they lost a whole
year of their education
um some of them were very lucky they got
very good
online teaching they were often in the
better schools the middle class schools
private schools i'm sad to say the kids
in the poorer areas
the disadvantage there is the kids
who've got more difficulties at school
struggled much more during the pandemic
and they needed to be helped but
rishi sunaka's blocked this so
dishi-rishi
the gloss comes off him just a little
bit here but i'm afraid it's also a
failure of the education secretary he
couldn't argue his way out of a wet
paper bag to be honest
uh he's got no voice in cabinet no
authority
nobody respects him no berates him but
ultimately the buck stops with um at the
top
well yes and if we move on to the metro
um kevin they
have it they they they've uh aiming
their criticism at gavin williamson as
well they say it's an f
for failed gavin i mean do you think
that's fair given that it appears to be
the treasury
uh that has blocked this demand
for money to try and help children and
and granted
about a tenth of what was asked for it
um yeah i think anna is both um
fair and unfair fair in the sense that
gavin williamson
is the education secretary he has a
woeful track record
go back to last summer and the big
problems over algorithms
and exam results but he had which he had
a back off and u-turn
on then there was all the problems um
just before last christmas and then
early january when he was insisting
schools must be open
threatening greenwich council in london
who happens to be liver-controlled
they ignore the tory councils are in the
same position who said they might have
to close schools early because they were
worried about the spread of the virus
and then he was bullying schools and
local authorities to reopen
in january reopened a day and then they
shut again
it just lurches from crisis to crisis so
i think the criticism
of him is fair i suppose what is unfair
is it's not him alone and yes it is
uh rishi sunak the the chancellor uh
winchester
uh head boy back in the day 40 000 pound
a year nice private
education for him when as kevin collins
makes clear it will be working class
kids
and those in the north where the prime
minister is supposed to be levelling up
not holding back kids who will suffer
most and then of course
the other guilty figure in this is the
prime minister
who's talked a very good game uh using
all sorts of superlatives
so on about how the government will get
this education recovery program going
and then when the man he appoints comes
up with a plan
he only gets a tenth of the money that
he thought he thought he would get so i
think i think
johnson and sunak are in there with
williamson
as the guilty trio here and they're
gonna fail kids these are kids
who could suffer for the rest of their
lives there was a report
some time ago that their incomes could
be lower
throughout their lives because of this
so it's really a matter of national
importance and johnson has said that
time after time talking about huge
massive programs
and then he comes up with something that
the person
he appointed to come up with a plan says
just
is not easy okay and andrew how do you
think that
other tory mps will react to this i mean
will they have
some sympathy with rishi sunak a huge
amount of money has been spent on the
pandemic will they say
it's not a bottomless pit we can't keep
spending
they will say that but it's just the
fact that the uh
and i and i have a lot of sympathy with
that too uh but
but it's just that the the the financial
settlement that sunac the chancellor
has agreed is i'm so woefully short of
what
uh colin's kevin collins wanted uh
and my worry about this is this look
these kids have already lost a year
we know the chance is probably going to
announce more money for the
for schools to recover in the autumn
statement
but that's now that's then we we need
these kids to be recovering
in the summer we want them to be able to
perhaps stay after school
you know summer schools we want them to
be able to perhaps have an extra half an
hour an hour
at the end of the day all of that could
have come from that money that kevin
collins wanted
and my worry is that some of these
children don't have time to wait to the
autumn statement they need
to get the some of this back they need
to because once
i mean that if you talk to teachers head
teachers they say
that year they lost last year is almost
irretrievable
and so waiting till the autumn statement
for the perhaps
there may be more money more jam
tomorrow i just don't think it's good
enough really and i think
many tory mps while understanding the
financial constraints
will be disappointed and really rather
cross okay and let's move on to
um another issue in the the government's
inbox if you like
this is travel back on the front page of
the daily telegraph they cover this with
talking about the green list potentially
being culled because tomorrow we do get
the first major review don't we kevin of
the
travel system obviously more countries
will want to go on to the green list but
the suggestion here is it could go in
the other direction
direction no that's right and there will
be a meeting of the joint biosecurity
center uh to discuss uh those 12
countries uh
whether any are added but it seems now
it's more likely they're going to be
taken away and there's this question
that portugal
which is one of the real uh destinations
on that list i don't think many people
are flying down
the falklands uh at the moment a bit of
a long way to go and not very uh
hospitable in the middle
of the winter down there so portugal is
where people's going and there's this
uh speculation it may be it may be taken
off now that the department of transport
is saying it's all
speculation but grand chaps is due to
update the
update the nation and when boris johnson
says he will have no hesitation
in acting if there is a problem in
somebody like
portugal that would be a first given his
two three week delay over india and 20
000 people possibly some uh some
infected coming in from that country
because he
delayed a decision because you wanted to
go and have a photo call
with the the leader uh there um but now
it's it seems that people booking um
summer holidays abroad now is an
absolute gamble you you pay your money
and you take you
take your chance because you may not
actually get there so instead of the
list being
expanded it could be narrowed again it's
probably good for
british and hoteliers and restaurateurs
and
pub owners but for the travel companies
that operate and send people abroad
it's uh it's an absolute nightmare a lot
of people do want to go
abroad and they may be frustrated yet
again
and if we look at the daily mail your
paper of course um andrew
perhaps a suggestion there of what the
government's worried about they're
worried about variants coming into the
country of course which is why
they may be stricter on travel policies
than others might want so what's your
paper suggesting uh
tomorrow well well we're now saying
we've got this exclusively that
ministers are now concerned about yet
another variant that's been identified
it's from nepal now at some point we'll
be told we can't call it
the nepal there i have to give it
another stupid name from the greek
alphabet which is ridiculous frankly
is it ridiculous isn't the idea that you
don't give a stigma to a particular
country and it just
i don't i i look the whole world is
suffering from uh
uh from covert so i don't i don't think
india's been particularly stigmatized
they had a massive crisis
with uh kovid and um it was a terrible
six terrible scenes in india
i don't feel i don't see why i've got to
call it out i'm sorry i'm going to carry
on calling it the indian variant
we still call it the kent variant don't
we for god's sake so
but but but i think this is being used
as an excuse by ministers
because there is a growing view that
actually
the government do not want people to go
on holiday abroad for two reasons
they're worried about various being
brought in well i've for once i agree
with maguire they should have got india
the indian
uh uh readily sorted out a bit quicker
but um because they want people to stay
here and spend their money here and they
want and i and that's
laudable in a way but i wish they'd just
be honest about it actually
because um if if they are going to make
it really difficult for us to go abroad
we don't want to start spending out on a
holiday
to portugal if we then discover in two
days time
it's not it's gone it's on the amber
list and then there are all sorts of
problems then with quarantining and
you've got to have all these
extra tests taken which cost an absolute
fortune and we're still charging v80 for
all these tests
and other countries don't so i think the
government are playing
a crafty game here they just don't want
us to go abroad and i'm not going abroad
okay i'll find out why you're going on
holiday a little later maybe but um and
just to pick out a
little line from your copy here in the
in the daily mail a member of the
government sage committee
i said officials shouldn't be overly
concerned about this variant there are
thousands of variants they say
it's a virus that's changing all the
time that's what they say there we're
going to take a pause right now but
don't go anywhere either of you we need
you for some time yet
uh coming up the multi-billion pound
tanks that can only go 20 miles an hour
we're going to be
talking about that after the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight andrew pearce
and kevin mcguire
and we're going to turn to a story
that's on the front of the telegraph
next kevin aren't we and this is about
um a fleet of tanks but there's there's
an issue that the
telegraph is picking out yeah
it is it's a it's a 3.5 billion fleet of
tanks
uh called uh it's like ajax or ijax i'm
not sure how they're pronouncing them
anywhere they're u.s
u.s maid and they're rubbish
miles uh power but they can't go faster
than 20 miles per hour because they're
damaging the health
of the soldiers inside they can't
reverse
backwards over any obstacle higher than
20 centimeters which is uh eight inches
that's not gonna be much good
in in a battle uh there are
they're four years late uh of one model
have ordered 589 there's only 14
being delivered it's yet another defense
procurement disaster really right not
unique
to this government it's happened on the
labor government's previous conservative
guns
i just can't understand how it's allowed
to still
go on and surely when these tank tanks
are designed they must put them through
trials before you get great big bulk
orders it seems these manufacturers take
huge amounts of public money
and then provide very poor equipment for
the
for the armed forces and it it's just
it's incredible
it happens year after year decade after
after decade andrew you're you're
nodding away there do
you agree i'm afraid i i agree you know
back in the 1980s michael hezel time
when he was the defense secretary you
never saw him out of a flak jacket to be
honest
he brought in a man from the city called
peter levine to sort out
defence procurement and for a few years
they seemed to get it right
but ever since it's been chaotic uh
budget's overrun ships and planes are
late
and this is just an embarrassment but
why did we buy american tanks in the
first place why didn't we buy
british tax why can't we buy british um
perhaps now we're
i mean we've got a fantastic defense
armaments industry
by british i mean maybe they'd have been
just as bad but this is
embarrassing and we need to we need a
statement from the defense secretary i
don't think we're going to see him at
the wheel of the tank that'd be famous
he's all
misleadingly sacked at the wheel of
attack do you remember all those years
ago
rather magnificent but i don't suppose
we're going to see boris or
the defense secretary ben wallace with
this bank in particular
kevin i'm just going to i'm going to cut
him i'm going to cut him i'm afraid i'd
be very rude because i didn't want to
get one more story in
from the metro and something i'm sure
you're looking forward to a
holiday to mark quit the queen's
platinum jubilee there are details in
the metro
but kevin can't go on that holiday
you're a republican you can stay at work
you don't want to be celebrating it
you're a republican outrageous look that
family
has been on welfare benefits for decades
it's about time poor taxpayers like me
got something back it might only be one
i'll give it up if it can be a republic
but otherwise
you can only only if you go to a street
party and behave properly and sing god
save the queen and you have some time
off
you know nobody will do that except a
few
monikers to kind of need their heads
seen too
you know that happens on these weekends
people just
go down the pub
thanks very much